d'autres secteurs se sentent abandonnés
par l'état c'est le cas de la recherche
et notamment les techniciens de
laboratoire il appelle à manifester à
travers le pays ce mardi
très mobilisés depuis le début de
l'épidémie il s'estime être les lésés du
ségur de la santé à plus de précision
avec notre reporter hamas m chelbi
journée de grève nationale aujourd'hui
les techniciens de laboratoire à l'appel
de la cgt santé pour le public et de la
cgt chimie pour le privé après les
grèves manifestations des 17 et 18 mai
dernier qui n'ont pas trouvé écho auprès
du gouvernement ils ont décidé de
remettre ça aujourd'hui afin de pouvoir
se faire entendre auprès des pouvoirs
publics
je vous propose d'écouter à ce sujet
etienne leclerc de la cgt santé
on souhaite être enfin visible mettre en
avant les incohérences que l'on vit
depuis le début de la crise sanitaire
on a un renouvellement de personnel
énorme parce que les gens saturent et ne
souhaite pas renouveler leur contrat
on a sous payés et exploiter ses
employés ils dénoncent des conditions de
travail précaires et ce depuis des
années la crise du coronavirus n'a été
que la goutte d'eau qui a fait déborder
le vase comme on déclaré à ses
personnels de santé ces techniciens de
laboratoire qui demandent une
augmentation de leurs salaires la
revalorisation des coefficients le
déplafonnement des primes d'ancienneté
ou encore la reconnaissance au niveau de
leur formation ils ont alerté le
gouvernement depuis des mois depuis le
début de la crise sanitaire sur leurs
conditions de travail ils ont même
déclaré que plusieurs d'entre eux
quittaient leurs fonctions il avait donc
du mal à renouveler les contrats se sont
comme on appelle les invisibles ceux qui
s'occupe notamment des tests pcr qui
sont au coeur de cette action au coeur
de la lutte du corona virus ils ont
également déclaré qu au niveau du ségur
de la santé que c'était une vaste
mascarade au vu de ce qui a été proposé
par le gouvernement a eu propose
notamment un plan d'urgence sanitaire
qui pourrait être financée par un impôt
progressif sur les grandes fortunes
voilà ce qui a été déclaré par la cgt
santé cgt chimie qui appellent à une
grève nationale
aujourd'hui des techniciens de
laboratoire